only go how're you guys doing here's my
old homie anymore Imam listen Betty's
the man I bet I've been talkin I'm just
gonna tell you I love you you know we've
been talking a lot about Cathy so we're
trying to motivate people to blessing
after after Imam is a person's health
and a lost planet I gave you your body
as an amount as a choice so you gotta
save you are the trust from Allah there
is no way you can be disciplined in
anything if you're not disciplined
everything right so if you're not
disciplined with your food if you're not
disciplined with your physical self
you're not going to be disciplined with
your spiritual self either so it's all
interconnected and the prophets length
of them was the greatest example of that
as he isn't everything else and not
overeating Salam alaikum guys how you
doing you know I've become very
passionate about something that every
one of us should be passionate about the
prophet sallallahu saw me said the two
things that people take for granted the
most is the free time wasting a lot of
time right when we should make a
productive time and then what health
take advantage of fourth of five before
five before the sickness comes
what are you doing it prevented to
protect your health to cherish it right
so we've been talking about eating real
food avoiding fake food and I found a
sister a medical doctor who's not about
just you know MD more drugs master drug
pushing the drugs no she's out here
really trying to get to the root of the
cause she's got a book the book is
called hold the holistic R X so we have
a show we're gonna give you a teaser a
little bit she's coming up on the D show
soon tell us a little bit about your
book and the work that you're doing I
thought like oh my god - who I am a
board certified family physician
I graduated residency in 2010 all my
siblings are physicians from every
specialty what I realized that we were
not taught a single class of nutrition
in residency but if you look at the
amount of training that I receive it was
probably about two or three hours in
medical school once I got out into
training my internship my residency
which was a five year long I don't think
I got any training at all and from then
on to now there's probably zero amount
of training and nutrition the poor
things don't study nutrition at medical
school and for the bulk of them post
qualification training consists of
courses that are dished out to them by
the pharmaceutical industry I'm pretty
skeptical about the quality of the
training that they receive having said
all that I went to med school myself
they gave us a whole hour on
nutritionals a whole hour in four years
of medical school mm-hmm and they told
us their site of an A and B 1 and B 2
and C & D in there in alphabetical order
and you can look them up and then they
told us some really basic facts we got a
whole hour first of all how much
training did you receive on nutrition
when you were in medical school because
I know here in the States
it's almost none yeah I know much not
much those two yeah yeah close to none
very little they don't teach you they
don't teach you anything about nutrition
and this is what is really key and
important is because of the fact that we
are what we eat
and all we are taught in medicine is
here's a problem here's a pill but what
conventional medicine does is it looks
at the root like the little leaves of a
tree and gives you a medication for each
symptom but not really recognizing the
underlining root cause which is
inflammation so once you can heal the
underlining would cause lower
inflammation you can heal not one
chronic symptom but then all of them
simultaneously Oakland Villa we have an
epidemic where one I write currently one
and every 36 children have autism one in
every two children have a chronic
condition that is not the new normal
that we need to adhere to we need to
focus on getting to the root cause of
these issues healing that so we can heal
and prevent chronic illnesses from our
generations and two years to come
because they say that we continue at the
current trajectory one out of every four
children will have autism by 2033
this has to stop now and what so
subhanAllah is that our Adeem is gran
Sanath has dictated exactly what we need
to do so if we just adhere to those we
can lower inflammation and heal and
prevent chronic illness everybody sister
many people like you said they haven't
connected the sickness food correlation
you know you have you mentioned no
statistics there's also 100 get this 100
million people with either pre-diabetes
or diabetes 100 million right one in two
men are expected to have cancer one in
three women and people they just haven't
connected what you put it you know you
eat something bad on my tummy hurts you
put something bad in the stomach and now
your health is being affected
we have over 600,000 fake food items out
there and people can't tell the
difference and they're not connecting
what they're eating with their sickness
and like you said they're going to the
medical doctor and then they're treating
the symptoms you just said something
that was an aha moment for me brothers
and sisters that you know as good
intention as many medical doctors are
and she's a medical doctor you don't
learn nutrition medicals
so people aren't connect they're good at
giving drugs managing symptoms but
getting to the root cause you know the
root problem and and briefly and we're
gonna have inshallah her on the show we
can talk about this more about the food
because ninety five percent they say 95
percent of chronic disease are food
related is connected to food and most
people they don't connect this to donuts
to Krispy Kreme you know all of the
other chips and cookies and Kay all of
the sugar items that are exciting the
taste buds yes for a longer shelf-life
and that's making you and your children
sick not not to talk about the rotting
teeth right so can you just talk about
the fake foods you know and then the
sickness food correlation what happens
is that food we are what we eat
I problem homeless as a mom says this
are the worst vessel we can fellas our
stomachs if I've got as disease our body
is disease if I got his healthy and body
is healthy I'm paraphrasing and also the
gut is a gateway to help we need to get
back to that philosophy and really focus
on what we need to put in our mouths to
help heal our bodies oh oh mankind
everybody eater which is halal and
William and there's direct correlations
with the foods that we eat the
environment that we live in can actually
even turn on and off our genes there's
an entire study known as epigenetics
that we can turn our genes on and off by
our environment and the biggest
connection between their insides and our
outsides is through our mouth our
digestive health so then we can even go
into a little bit more detail because we
our gut has a hundred trillion bacteria
that align our gut lining or we are only
ten to thirty two trillion human cells
so it's mind-blowing because 70 to 80
percent of our immune system also lies
in the gut
so just buy the foods that we eat it can
change your genes and it can cause
inflammation because of the fact they
were killing off all those good bugs
that we need a net to keep us healthy
jut because that's what fake food do
does fake food makes you sicker fake
environment a rap like artificial
chemicals in our environment makes it
thicker our world we are turning away
from Imperial we're getting going
towards impurities and those impurities
are making us sick as a generation the
statistics don't lie we have this
exciting episode and again let me and
the book here by dr. Medina Sayid doctor
MD and these are the doctors that we
need to connect with doctors like this
who are going above and beyond just a
conventional she's got the conventional
license but she's going above and beyond
the drugs she's looking for the root
problem that's what connects with us
avoid the fake foods eat the raw foods
and look forward to her episode coming
up on the Dean show
thank you sister Salaam alaikum to Lanka
no stranger to the Dean show
we got Imam Suleiman to comment on this
this ayah amongst the understandings for
us as believers is that this verse in
the Quran is one of these signs and
reminders that as believers we generally
submit and believe and this is backed up
by modern medicine backed up by studies
backed up by
listing nutrition which is that the
claim of eating a playa and that which
is how that as well slaughtered a
certain way the claim of eating a bite
of that which is pure that which is good
for you is a reminder for us and again
this is backed up by medicine is backed
up by studies a reminder for us to eat
as realistically and naturally as
possible to try to get closer to Allah
so cantata through that as well and to
realize that this is something that is
healthy for not just our stomachs and
not just for our bodies for our minds as
well and this affects the decisions that
we make as human beings it affects our
ways of life it affects many other
things it causes a prevention in
protection from all types of diseases as
well as arms because it is by iam so it
could be considered an act of worship to
eat politically as well among Adam now
do you wait for the health to go bad
and then you go chase peculiar or you
take advantages as even an island it
talks about you know in his book you
know this position the great scholar he
says the one who has been granted out of
his fortune he protects it from harm
there's over six hundred thousand plus
fake food items hundred million thousand
people out there with diabetes
preventable diseases this is going over
a lot of person's health even scholars
even you know are enjoying the food
they're addicted they're not making the
food correlation with significant
whatsoever we're supposed to take
preventative measures the same way we're
taking preventive measures in our faith
with a year out there you're not waiting
to get to the hereafter and then find
out that you just believed that you were
wrong and so on and so forth it's the
same thing in this life you take
advantage while you can with your good
health you do what you have to do to
protect and preserve this blessing from
allah subhanaw taala
we see around us the vast majority of
the world's problems in terms of bodily
diseases are due to an issue with eating
habits are due to an issue with what we
are consuming as a nation and as a race
and then on the other end the issue of
time as well there's a loss product but
again it for both of these matters one
more thing in work out tell us all how
can we we're trying to get this morning
of replacing the fake food what you do
in your home okay that's fine you want
to continue to eat the fake foods more
common within the Masjid you know not
only check decay one is to kick people
have a chronic disease cancer and all of
these things that are affecting people's
help getting the fake foods out of the
Masjid you know with with with the
cookies the cakes and you know many of
the chips and all the GMOs and all these
things but look replacing it with the
easy solution bananas pears apples ate
like sugar how could we get your new mom
right tell us you know for the other
UMass people who for again not
connecting what the food we're putting
in you know to the sicknesses to get
this fake food under the moistures and
people might do some food so they can
have real good and prevent the potential
harm that can come from eating fake
foods absolutely I actually do have some
suggestions and I believe in every
community there should be some people
with experience of people are proficient
in the matter and I'm really grateful
and glad to see that there's a rise and
a trend in people understanding this
issue in our own community for example
we've made it in a big matter to have a
workshop every year is awareness about
this matter we have a local nutritionist
actually my sister Pamela and every
sitting we have people are proficient we
have the sisters also proficient inner
city I hope that the masajid are using
and taking advantage of these amazing
gems in their communities so that there
are workshops held to educate a
community to raise more awareness as
well as having something in the message
it in which there's an official way to
do things so when the mission hasn't if
gone when the Michigan has an event
there are certain things that will no
longer be done no more soda as an
example so these types of things should
continue to be taught generation after
generation so that we're leaving
something good behind in our communities
and it's not just based on we're not
just teaching religious knowledge we're
not focusing on one aspect of their
faith but all of these different aspects
that are comprehensive beneficial for
the community of beneficial for our
health and I see one momzilla mark and
the DS show gonna be talking some more
discipline hi thank you something watch
the game show lost the deed zone make
sure you watch the dude show watch the
Dean so watch the Dean so watch the Dean
so watch the beautiful